Efforts to ban flavored e-cigarettes,
while understandable, will cause more
harm than good.
Some vapers will simply resume smoking
deadly cigarettes; others will seek out
dangerous counterfeit vapes.
E-cigarettes are considerably safer than
cigarettes and flavors are a powerful
incentive for effective use by adults.
E-cigarettes deliver nicotine as an
aerosol, while cigarettes burn tobacco.
It's the smoke from burning tobacco,
not the nicotine, that contains carcinogenic tar.
Now, we don't know the health effects
of years of inhaling e-cigarette aerosol.
Researchers will need to follow vapers
for many years, and this uncertainty is
why non-smokers should not start to vape.
One of the biggest concerns about teens —
that vaping leads to more teen smoking — has not
happened, so the FDA should not
ban flavors. Other steps can be taken to
reduce teen access to e-cigarettes.
Meanwhile, we need to protect safer
alternatives to cigarettes for those who
already vape, and the 35 million American
smokers who have yet to quit.
What do you think? Should the US
ban flavored e-cigarettes?
Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.